نعم نعم اسمعك الان الميكروفون
معك لم اكمل السؤال
ولكن ابدا بان اقول رحم الله زميلي
سامر بالتاكيد يصعب علي ان اتحدث عن سامر
بصيغه الماضي ولكن ستحدث عن سامر زميل
ساتحدث الان عن سامر الانسان سامر عمل معي
ومع مكتب الجزيره لاكثر من 20 عام سامر
كان زميلا لي واخ وزميل واخ لجميع طقم
الجزيره سامر كان معروف بانه مصور مبدع
وكان يعمل معنا ايضا في المونتاج وشاركنا
لسنوات طويله هو من يتابع تعلى اعداد
التقارير بالتالي انا ساتحدث عن سامر
المصور المبدع المهني المحترف ساتحدث عن
سامر الاخ الصديق الزميل ساتحدث عن سامر
الانسان المرح الانسان الذي كان يضفي
اجواء جميله ومرحه على كل تجمعاتنا ساتحدث
عن طاقم الجزيره الذي نعيش فيه كاسره
واحده نحن في قناه الجزيره ومنذ 20 عاما
عندما بدات العمل في قناه الجزيره عشنا
داخل مكتب الجزيره كاسره واحده لم يعطنا
هذه الدفعه وهذه القوه وهذا التماسك الا
الشعور العالي بانتمائنا لقناه الجزيره
وانتمائنا لهذه الرساله التي تخدم ابناء
شعبنا بالتالي كل فرد فينا كان لديه بصمه
في بقائنا في ثباتنا في عملنا في اصار
رسالتنا سامر انسان رائع وكانت اليوم ما
حدث لزميلي سامر ووائل صدمه شديده لنا نحن
نعلم كيف يتم العمل في الميدان نحن نتوخى
الحذر نحن نحافظ على جميع ايه طرق السلامه
التي يجب ان تتبع في الميدان وبالتالي انا
اكيده وشاهدنا الصور بما اي كان يفعله
وائل وسامر من ارتداء الدروع وارتداء
الخوذات وشاهدنا ايضا شيرين ابو عقله في
هذه الموقف ايضا ولكن شاهدنا ايضا جيش
احتلال اسرائيلي محتل لا يراعي
اي قيم ولا يتبع اي قوانين ولا يلتزم باي
مواثيق دوليه وبالتالي استمرار استهدافنا
ك قناه الجز زيره استهدافنا
كصحفي هذا دليل واضح امام العالم بان صوت
الحقيقه والصوره التي تنقلها شاشتنا وقناه
الجزيره هي تنقل الواقع هي تنقل ما يحدث
للشعب الفلسطيني هي فقط عين لهذا العالم
على ما يحدث لدينا هي عين لهذا العالم
وكانت في هذه الحرب نحن اليوم نتحدث عن 70
يوما لم نرتح فيهم يوم واحدا لم نتوقف عن
نقل ما يدور في اراضي قطاع غزه نحاول
الوصول الى كل مكان وبالتالي قد يعني
هذا ضيق كبير ل من يشاهد هذه الح الحقائق
التي لا يريد للعالم ان يشاهدها نحن ننقل
ما يدور على الارض وخير دليل على ذلك وجود
زميلي وائل وسامر اليوم لينقلوا ما يحدث
على ارض الواقع انا في هذه الحرب دعني
اتحدث ثواني فقط عن ميشتي لسامر عشت مع
سامر 60 يوم من بدايه هذه الحرب وحتى
انتقلت من رفح الى خانيونس نتابع احداث في
كل يوم طوال ساعات المساء كان سامر لا
يتوقف عن العمل يتابع
معي الفقرات على الشاشه و بين
هذه الرسائل واللفات على الشاشه كان ياخذ
كاميراته ويتوجه فورا الى المدخل المشفى
ليتابع صور الشهداء وصور ال المصابين كان
في كل مره ينقل لي هذه الصور وياتي لي
يريني صور الاطفال يقول لي هبه انظري الى
هذه الصور كل من يشاهد هؤلاء الاطفال
يتخيل انهم اطفاله فكيف ونحن
طوال هذه الايام في الحرب لا نكون مع
ابنائنا ومع اسرنا نشاهد هذه الماسي يوميا
وكنا نتحدث كثيرا عن ما يتعرض له الشعب
الفلسطيني ما نتعرض له نحن يقول لي ودائما
نتحدث بهذه الصيغه نحن الان نتحدث هل نعلم
غدا كيف سيكون مصيرنا هل يقف هذا الجيش
الاسرائيلي هذا الجيش المحتل عند حد ويوقف
هذا هذه الاباده لشعبنا الفلسطيني هذا ما
كنا نتحدث وعندما كنا نتحدث وخاصه بعد ان
بدات اسر زملائنا تتعرض لهذا الموت المحقق
وهذه الاستهدافات دائما كنا نقول من سيكون
التالي كنا نقولها احيانا لنخفف عن نفسنا
لاقتراب هذا الموت منا جميعا في قطاع غزه
لا يوجد مكان مستثنى ولا يوجد مكان امن لا
يوجد اي حصا لاي احد لا يوجد اي اعتبار
لاي قوانين ومواثيق وحتى حقوق الصحفي التي
يتجلى بها العالم وينادي بها العالم تنتهك
عللا الان امام العالم ولكن ما يصدر فقط
هو شعارات وما يصدر هو مطالبات وعلى ارض
الواقع هنا نحن نتعرض لهذه الانتهاكات
نتحدث اليوم عن سامر الذي اصبح الشهيد ال0
في الصحافه في قطاع غزه خلال هذه الايام
السبين اليوم سامر اصبح في هذا الموكب من
الشهداء الصحفيين عشرات الصحفيين من
زملائنا كنت اشاهدهم اشاهدهم يوميا وهم
ينتقلون الى الاماكن المستهدفه ويتعرضون
ايضا اثناء تغطيتهم لهذه الاحداث لاستهداف
من قبل الطيران او المدفعيه او حتى اطلاق
النار المباشر على هؤلاء الصحفيين ليوقفوا
هذا الصوت ويوقفوا تدفق هذه الصور ويوقف
ايصال الحقيقه للعالم ولكن نحن ساهمنا في
ايصال هذه الرساله وايصال هذا الصوت
وايصال هذه الصوره ولكن ماذا فعل العالم
في المقابل استمرار لانتهاكات واباده وقتل
وهدم وتدمير وحصار
وتجويع كل ابناء قطاع غزه وبالتالي انا
اتحدث عن سامر الذي ضحى الذي اعطى الذي
ترك لنا بصمه جميله باجواء جميله باجواء
الفرح
واجواء دائما الابتسامه على وجه سامر ولكن
انا اذكر دائما الابداع والتميز والمرافق
سامر لم يكن
فقط
انسان متفائل مرح محب للحياه
ولكنه كان صحفيا متمسكا برسالته صحفيا
يعطينا دفعه دائما عندما اشعر بال الالم
او اشعر
بالاحباط كان سامر دائما الروح الجميله
التي ترافقنا ويمدنا دائما بالضحكه في كل
المواقف كان سامر يضفي الضحكه ويضفي
الاجواء الجميله وكنا عندما ندعم سامر
بانه بعيد عن اسرته بان وقت اقترب يا سامر
ستقابل اسرتك كان يقول لي لن اذهب لهم
سياتون لي وسنكون في غزه سويا مره ثانيه
اقول انه يصعب علي بالفعل ان اتحدث عن
سامر بصيغه الماضي سامر سيبقى موجود كما
ستبقى شيرين كما ستبقى الصحافه كما ستبقى
شاشه الجزيره تنقل الحقيقه وتنقل هذه الع
عين التي ترى كل ما يحدث على اراضينا
الفلسطينيه تنقلها للعالم بكل مصداقيه بكل
واقعيه هي فقط توضح للعالم ما يحدث ويواصل
العالم تجاهله
وتعمد اغفال ما يحدث في ارضنا وان كل ساعه
تمر هنا تعني المزيد من الدمار تعني
المزيد من القتل تعني المزيد من المعاناه
تعني زيد من الجرائم ضد الانسانيه امام
مراه العالم ولكن يستمر هذا الحال ولكن مع
وجود ابطال صحافه وشاشه كشاشه الجزيره
وناس ينقلون بكل صدق هذه الرساله جميع
زملائي الصحفيين ينقلون فعلا بكل مصداقيه
ولو تجاب او تراجعنا لن يبقى احد هنا ولكن
هذا ما عهدناه من اصحاب ه هذه الرساله
ستبقى شيرين فينا وسيبقى سامر فينا وستبقى
الحقيقه لكل العالم تصل شكرا وانا اكيده
بانه اذا تجاهل العالم الان هذه الحقائق
لن يبقى متجاهلا لان هناك في
النهايه من ارحم م جميعا رحم الله زميلنا
سامر وسيبقى في قلوبنا كما ستبقى
شيرين شكرا هبه عكيله و